bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
qui va démarrer et d'ici quinze minutes
parmi les thèmes qui vont être abordés
dans l'hémicycle du sénat cet après midi
et bien la situation au mali de question
également sur les réformes
constitutionnelles envisagée par le
gouvernement
une question sur le grand paris une
autre sur les retraites et enfin une
question également sur la dépendance
donc des thèmes très variés on pourra
suivre en direct sur notre antenne cette
séance à partir de 15 heures mais avant
nous recevons le vice-président du sénat
didier guillaume bonjourbonjour sénateur
ps de la drôme merci d'être avec nous à
dijon il ya deux jours le chef de l'état
a dit il faut forcer l'alluré pour
atteindre la bonne direction
est-ce que ça justifie le recours à des
ordonnances non messieurs c'est beaucoup
plus large que cela il faut forcer
l'alluré parce que effectivement la
situation de notre pays est
catastrophique que nos concitoyens
souffrent sont en attente
certains sont même déçus de la situation
est aujourd'hui il faut donner des
signes donner un cap et le président de
la république a une ligne
il doit donner ce cap et en même temps
les lois que nous votons séparation des
activités bancaires la mise en place de
la banque publique d'investissement les
contrats de génération des emplois
d'avenir et beaucoup d'autres choses
sont les fondements de la politique mais
il n'y a pas de résultats immédiats et
le président dit nous voulons des
résultats immédiats pour ceux qui
souffrent le plus et qui ont besoin de
se rendre compte que la politique menée
par le gouvernement sous la houlette du
chef de l'état va dans leur direction
vous vous identifiez un cap de la
paruline de la part du gouvernement
d'autres à gauche au sein du parti
socialiste sont un petit peu plus de mal
à voir où va cette ligne je pense
notamment votre collègue le sénateur
socialiste et maire de lyon gérard
collomb qui dans une interview il ya des
jours disait françois hollande doit
avoir un langage plus clair
oui mais ça veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas
l'hallali non là le cap il est là c'est
le chômage le chômage le chômage la
réduction la diminution du nombre de
chômeurs ce fléau ce cancer qui ronge le
corps et être clair c'est peut-être les
moyens et en même temps
il faut réduire la dette réduire la
dette parce que 600 milliards de plus de
déficit ce n'est pas possible ces cinq
dernières années il faut réduire la
dette
mais pour ce faire nous avons mis en
place des moyens des outils mais ce
n'est pas assez visible pour nos
concitoyens
voilà c'est clair ils ne sont pas assez
lisible pour nos concitoyens
parce que si on parle à des français qui
ne payent pas d'impôts qui sont au
chômage ou qui sont en grande difficulté
la banque publique d'investissement ça
ne les touche pas directement la
séparation des activités bancaires ça ne
touche pas directement le budget de
l'europe ça ne les touche pas
directement et pourtant ces mesures sont
fondamentales
donc le gouvernement sous lac
saint-françois goji n est pas il faut
vraisemblement que le président de la
république
si j'ai bien compris il va s'exprimer
devant les français dans les jours ou
les semaines qui viennent
ça vous attendait ce moment oui un très
important parce qu'il doit retracer la
voix redéfinir le cas pour les français
le comprennent le mieux possible mais
cela ne suffit pas faire de la politique
ça ne peut pas être uniquement du sang
et des larmes
je pense que nos concitoyens ont compris
que les temps étaient difficiles comme
jamais que la situation que traverse le
pays est désastreuse liés à ce que nous
avons vécu depuis dix ans et puis à
l'aggravation de la crise
c'est évident et en même temps il faut
que les françaises et les français
voient le plus rapidement possible des
avancées les concernant les mesures qui
sont prises vont dans le bon sens elles
sont bonnes mais elles ne sont pas assez
lisible pour nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle ce cap que dont
vous parlez que le président de la
république va à nouveau expliquer aux
français devrait être plus lisible pour
nos concitoyens
c'est pour cette raison à votre avis que
françois hollande est en ce moment au
plus bas dans les sondages mais bien sûr
bien sûr mais vous savez des sondages ça
va ça vient ça dure plus longtemps un
certain moment que d'autres peu importe
j'ai toujours une indication en mai
l'ong est sûre c'est une indication mais
la crise gronde et nos concitoyens ne
sont pas satisfaits de ce qu'ils voient
et je le comprends
moi je rencontre dans la drôme beaucoup
de mes amis beaucoup des citoyens
drômois qui me disent ce que tu fais à
paris c'est sûrement bien mais nous on
n'en voit pas tout de suite les
résultats
il faudra aussi d'assumer clairement les
choses et de prononcer des mots qui font
parfois un peu peur
comme rigueur austérité mais aujourd'hui
il ne faut pas de politique
anxiogène il ne faut pas dire aux
françaises et aux français à nos
concitoyens tout va mal et ça ira encore
plus mal de manon risque de brouiller le
message avec des messages il n'est pas
brouiller il faut simplement eu que la
ligne claire que le cap politique fixée
par le président de la république et des
effets plus rapidement auprès de nos
concitoyens
c'est ça l'enjeu de la pote ki vien le
président de la république va devoir
réexpliqué cela et puis il faut que le
gouvernement
un pack soudé comme devrait l'être celui
de l'équipe de france même si elle
souffre un peu de rugby que ce cap sans
ce soit le plus soudé possible se serre
les coudes et avant dans la même
direction
c'est ce qu'il faut mais vous savez la
crise que nous traversons la complexité
de la société
nous n'avons jamais connu comme celle là
et c'est normal qu'il puisse y avoir des
petites difficultés parfois ce qui
compte c'est l'objectif et surtout à
moyen terme
c'est ce que nos concitoyens verront
s'apercevront des effets des politiques
mises en place par françois hollande et
le gouvernement sur justement la
cohésion au sein des gouvernements est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec françois
rebsamen
quand il a déclaré cette semaine il
faudrait que jean marc ayrault le
premier ministre wihr intimiste pour
donner l'exemple
il n'a pas déclaré ça cette semaine il
la pile a pu le dire il a revendiqué
qu'il l'a dit mais ne commentons pas les
petites phrases on n'a pas de montrer du
doigt tel ou tel ce n'est pas la
question
je pense que vous pensez au-delà de ça
est ce qui est au delà la petite phrase
est ce que vous pensez que le premier
ministre doit faire preuve d'un peu plus
d'autorité que je pense que lorsqu'on
joue on fait du sport lorsqu'on joue au
rugby
la première mi temps il peut peut-être
mal se passer et la première mi temps
que nous venons de vivre depuis combien
dire depuis le mois de mai dire la
première la première mi temps l aile
dure du 9 mai dernier du 15 mai dernier
à aujourd'hui
maintenant il faut un nouveau souffle il
faut repartir à la reconquête allard
comportement en agence nous à la
reconquête de la population à la
reconquête de nos concitoyens en
incarnant tenant un discours clair juste
et unique
il n'y a pas tous les jours des idées
nouvelles qui doivent sortir
on ne peut pas expliquer simplement nos
concitoyens que c'est dur et que ce sera
encore plus dur demain
moi je soutiens la politique menée par
le gouvernement sous la houlette du
président de la république il faut
maintenant dire qu'il ya des choses
vers lesquels nous ne pourrons pas aller
malgré la difficulté l'augmentation
d'impôts ce n'est plus les augmentations
d'impôts ce n'est plus possible pour les
classes populaires et pour les classes
moyennes
il faut réduire les déficits ni
complémentation de la tva mais si c'est
pour besset député socialiste préconise
une augmentation de la tva
la politique ce n'est pas bout par bout
secteur par secteur c'est un dispositif
global et cohérent
donc il faudrait tel concours lépine par
exemple jusqu'à 5 à 10 francs vous avez
raison il a hélas raison
le problème ce ne sont pas les petites
phrases il faut maintenant un dispositif
d'ensemble est cohérent et moi je me
refuse à dire ben et là nous allons
augmenter les impôts
là nous allons baisser les pensions pour
les retraités non les retraités guyenne
1000 euros par mois qui ont du mal à
avoir un logement
et quand on veut aller dans une maison
de retraite on n'a pas les moyens d'y
aller ce n'est plus possible
plutôt nouveau modèle fallait s'en va
leur demander plus d'efforts puisque
l'accord qui a été signé hier entre le
medef et certains syndicats sur les
retraites complémentaires autres
retraités dont les retraites
complémentaires c'est une chose mais moi
je parlais de la grande réforme des
retraites que nous aurions dû faire
depuis des années celle contre laquelle
et 17 par le gouvernement précédent à
laquelle nous sommes battus bec et
ongles parce qu'elle ne servait à rien
et nous a person aujourd'hui qu'elle
n'est pas financé que quelques mois
après que cette loi entre sur les
retraites entre en imaginant sorte
qu'elle n'allait pas assez loin visible
et canal et elles n'étaient pas financés
donc aujourd'hui la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est d'avoir une nouvelle
réforme
donc ce n'est pas sérieux on peut plus
faire des réformes est on peut plus
faire des allers retours des retraites
c'est à dire quoi on augmente les
cotisations on avance l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite en plus tôt on
recule pardon oui mais moi je pense
qu'on ne peut pas aborder la ligne
politique aujourd'hui
secteur par secteur moi ce que j'attends
du président de la république c'est une
cohérence globale
on ne peut pas dire là on joue sur la
tva et puis un autre jour on joue sur
les impôts puis un autre jour en joue
sur les retraites la durée ou le montant
des pensions
moi ce que j'attends de mon président de
la république et de mon gouvernement du
gouvernement de la france et du
président de la république française
c'est tout simplement que le cap qui
était défini pendant l'élection
présidentielle que les orientations qui
vont être mises en place
il faut les mettre sur la table ça peut
être tous les deux mois ou tous les
quinze jours
pour une nouvelle mesure qui dont on ne
comprendra pas la cohérence
il faut de la cohérence donc on verra ça
mais défense et son intervention
télévisée de france à la fin du mois de
mars dit guillaume pour reprendre ma
première question tout à l'heure il faut
aller plus vite a dit le chef de l'état
à dijon cette semaine est ce que ça
justifie le recours à des ordonnances
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
lis je suis d'accord mais je ne suis pas
d'accord si pour aller plus vite il faut
des ordonnances alors oui je suis
d'accord pourquoi parce que sur le oui
bien sûr mais tous les gouvernements les
ont utilisés ça dépend de quoi l'on
parle
si c'est pour enlever des normes absurde
qui gangrènent la société qui empêche le
développement de certains secteurs et
qui coûte cher oui 450000 normes tous
les ans ce n'est pas possible
si c'est pour mettre un coup
d'accélérateur pour le logement pour la
rénovation de logements oui mais
aujourd'hui les ordonnances et sûrement
sensible mais qu'on ne dise pas que le
parlement est bafouée vous savez ma
grand mère disait toujours quand on veut
noyer son chien on l'accuse de la rage
si je constate ce qui s'est passé depuis
neuf mois le parlement a été au coeur de
toutes les grandes lois et de tous les
grands débats mais là il s'agit quand
même de passer au dessus des
prérogatives et par la non pas au dessus
des priorités puisque lorsqu'il ya des
ordonnances de toute façon les
méditations et ben oui donc c'est pas au
dessus le parlement elle est plus vite
de l'étang des vacances mais je vais je
vais vous dire une chose qui pourrait
être opposé au fait que l'on accélère la
construction de logements dans le vent
des normes pour permettre à nos
concitoyens que sont le plus mal logé
dia les personnes alors on peut toujours
dire il faut que ça passe au parlement
et puis débattre et débattre et je suis
un parlementaire qui aime qui adore le
parlement et qui parce que le parlement
doit être respecté et je pense qu'il est
mais pour ce genre de chose pour les
normes pour le logement
s'il faut aller plus vite parce qu'il ya
des blocages de leurs riches soutiennent
président de la république parce que
c'est de toute urgence moi je rencontre
dans mon département des gens qui n'ont
pas de logement adapté leurs familles
dont les enfants dans ma 3 dans 1 9
mètre carré ce n'est pas possible tous
là bas tout le travail qui n'a pas été
fait il faut accélérer le mettre en
place maintenant alors on verra
effectivement les contours de ces
ordonnances
s'il ya urgence sur les réformes
structurelles à faire apprendre en
france pourquoi présenter alors quatre
projets de loi de révision
constitutionnelle est ce que ça c'était
primordial pour cette année 2013 ça ne
pouvait pas attendre
non mais
un de primordial ce qui est primordial
c'est l'économie et le social ça moi je
vous le dis très tranquillement mais en
même temps la réforme constitutionnelle
c'est des choses qui avait dit dans la
campagne qu'il faut bien faire c'est
comme la réformer mais voilà c'est pas
le problème
l'urgence pour prêt pour présenter des
lois de cohérent sur l'économie et le
social
il faut prendre du temps la loi
constitutionnelle ça fait partie des
symboles le mariage pour tous on va me
dire il y avait pas urgence
enfin il est fait il va être voté au
sénat en quelques jours et ça sera fait
en quadri symbole de campagne le droit
de vote des étrangers
là pour le coup et le droit dit yves
m'en écarter il est pas définitivement
écartée pas du tout mais ce que nous
constatons qu'un majorité c'est tout ce
que nous disons ce n'est pas de
l'agitation quotidienne comme on a pu
voir ces dernières années mais c'est de
l'action
donc à quoi cela servirait-il de
présenter au parlement une loi sur le
droit de vote des étrangers pour qu'elle
soit rejetée et bien le travail dès que
nous avons à faire nous les socialistes
et la gauche et le gouvernement c'est de
trouver une majorité et le parti
socialiste doit s'atteler à trouver une
majorité
plutôt que de réclamer tous les jours
plus de ceux ci plus de cela le droit de
vote je pense que c'est ça cette façon
de gérer le pays et différente de ce que
nous avons connu il faut s'y habituer
peut-être il ya un temps de de sevrage
et des dires de l'agitation quotidienne
par rapport à la sérénité et à la
constance du message du président de la
république et sur les quatre projets de
loi de révision constitutionnelle qui
sont présentes est ce que vous pensez
que les quatre ont les chances de passer
le stade du congrès et obtenir une
majorité des trois cinquièmes écoutez je
l'espère le président de la république
puis le premier ministre a lancé des
consultations avec les organisations
politiques représentés au parlement ou
de boire même toutes les organisations
politiques
aujourd'hui il y aurait pu avoir
d'autres choses dans cette réforme
constitutionnelle ce n'est pas passé ce
n'est pas présentée c'est la politique
de pas à pas marche après marche la
grande ligne la grande orientation de
gouvernement c'est la lutte contre le
chômage c'est la cohésion sociale et
c'est notre modèle français
et puis lorsque l'on peut faire d'autres
avancées sociétales comme l'on dit nous
les faisons c'est pas les unes sans les
autres les unes opposé aux autres
il ya un temps pour tout 1 ce qu'elle
cumule les mandats soit resté aussi une
des priorités du gouvernement
mais le vote gouvernement peut avoir que
des priorités il a cinq ans pour le
faire la limitation du cumul des mandats
sera votée au parlement et s'appliquera
lorsqu'elle devra s'appliquer
mais regardez vous voulez accéléré sur
tous les sujets moi mon objectif annoncé
je vais accélérer
c'est de faire en sorte que la vie de
nos concitoyens
aïe le mieux possible et le plus
rapidement c'est plus que faisait cette
question-là totale et immédiate pour les
le tiennent le film il des mandats c'est
pas une urgence pour la vie quotidienne
des français la loi électorale c'est pas
là que pour le quotidien des français
urgent mais il faut tout faire à la fois
l'objectif c'est le chômage la lutte
contre le chômage l'emploi la cohésion
sociale la lutte contre la pauvreté et
en même temps il ya tout un tas de
projets de loi qui doivent se dérouler
parce que cinq ans c'est long mais c'est
court donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que l'on juge françois hollande et son
gouvernement et ses ministres sur la
durée des cinq ans les 60 avec
engagement de françois hollande lors de
la campagne présidentielle c'était pour
cinq ans il ya des choses qui vont vite
peut-être que aujourd'hui la moitié de
ces engagements sont déjà réalisés ou en
cours de l'être
c'est très bien d'autres neutrons plus
de temps c'est la vie mais au bout de
ces cinq ans il y aura l'issue
racontable devant les français pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle
pour l'instant il ya les mesures
d'urgence les ordonnances il y en a
besoin pour le logement etc
ça se fera et le rsa se fait au rythme
où il ya de la place dans le parlement
le calendrier parlementaire peut les
intégrer
donc vous rester confiant ni dégâts oui
moi je suis je suis inquiet je suis
inquiet de voir les françaises et les
français eux mêmes très inquiet
interrogatifs et les enfants puis
c'était évidemment et je l'entends
là je suis inquiet mais je ne suis pas
pisser dooku interpellé sur le terrain
puisque beaucoup beaucoup moi la semaine
dernière qu'une semaine de vacances
parlementaires
j'ai été beaucoup ce terrain j'en ai
profité et lundi encore dans deux
réunions dont une réunion avec beaucoup
de monde lundi soir j'étais beaucoup
interpellé et je suis remonté dans mon
tgv qui a été bloqué par la neige donc
pendant 4 heures j'ai eu le temps de
beaucoup réfléchir à ça et je me suis
dit elle il ya des messages à faire
passer
vous voyez fait passer j'espère il faut
c'est un des premiers mini j'espère il
faut entendre la colère de certains de
nos concitoyens
il faut entendre la grande inquiétude il
faut entendre l'impatience parce que le
pays va mal et que les français
souffrent à nous de répondre à cela par
une politique cohérente sérénité
cohérence et volontarisme et plus après
le reste viendra mais il faut des choses
qu'ils aillent
plus vite qu'elle de vente aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup et bien sûr guillaume
d'être venu délivrer ce message sur le
plateau de public cela on va repartir
dans l'hémicycle plus que la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement va
démarrer d'ici à peine une petite minute
je pense on le voit les ministres le
gouvernement et s'installe dans les
musiques je vous laisse vous même didier
guillaume rejoindre l'hémicycle merci
d'avoir été notre invité je vous
rappelle que parmi les thèmes abordés
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat
et bien il ya une question sur les
retraites une autre sur la situation au
mali deux questions autour des révisions
constitutionnelles engagées par le
gouvernement
une question également du groupe des
verts sur la gouvernance de renault
voilà jean pierre bel le président du
sénat lance les questions d'actualité on
les suit on se retrouve après avec nos
invités en direct à partir de 16h à tout
à l'heure au gouvernement je rappelle
avec insistance que l'auteur de la
question de même que le ou la ministre
pour sa réponse disposent chacun de deux
minutes trente
la parole est à madame valérie létard
pour le groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants uc
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé madame la ministre
lundi dernier trois rapports ont été
remis au premier ministre en vue
d'élaborer une loi d'adaptation de la
société au vieillissement
ces contributions viennent s'ajouter des
travaux déjà nombreux en 2011 déjà
quatre groupes de travail ont été
engagés quatre groupes de concertation
sous l'égide de bertrand fragonard et
avait déjà fait un large tour du sujet
piloté par madame bachelot favoriser la
prévention du vieillissement limiter le
recours à l'hospitalisation adapter le
cadre de vie permettre le maintien à
domicile
améliorer la formation des
professionnels et des aidants familiaux
promouvoir une logique de guichet unique
nous sommes tous d'accord sur ses
objectifs
tous nous défendons l'idée du
vieillissement chance et opportunité
pour la france mais la question du
financement est pour l'instant laissée
de côté
elle est pourtant essentiel l'enjeu
c'est 26 milliards d'euros
comment vieillir à domicile avec un
handicap lourd si le financement des
intervenants n'est pas assurée comme
entrée dans un ehpad si le reste à
charge des familles n'est plus
compatible avec le niveau des retraites
une question d'autant plus problématique
que le poids financier des allocations
apa prestation de compensation du
handicap aide sociale aux personnes
âgées pèse de plus en plus lourdement
sur les départements en particulier les
départements pauvres et que ce poids va
s'alourdir encore dans les années à
venir tandis que votre gouvernement a
décidé de réduire fortement les
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales
ma question est donc simple madame la
ministre au delà des bonnes intentions
qu'on ne peut que partager
comment comptez vous améliorer la
réponse aux besoins des personnes âgées
est particulièrement pérenniser le
financement de ces aides sont détricotés
le socle nécessaire de la solidarité
nationale et recourir comme on l'entend
aujourd'hui à l'assurance privée
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous
donner des pistes
de travail du gouvernement sur ce point
essentiel je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
merci monsieur le président madame
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice valérie létard le
premier ministre a reçu trois rapports
permettant d'approfondir les travaux que
le gouvernement a engagé pour répondre
aux grands défis du vieillissement de
notre société
ce grand défi est aussi une chance pour
notre pays il ne nous soulignons pas
assez vivre plus longtemps vivre en
bonne santé est aussi un atout dans la
compétitivité de la france cela
représente des marges des perspectives
de croissance pour une économie qui
devra répondre aux besoins de cette
population
le gouvernement a engagé la réflexion et
le vin michèle delaunay travaillent avec
moi mais à l'élaboration d'un texte de
loi qui doit nous permettre de répondre
aux attentes des français en la matière
comment mieux prévenir l'arrivée de la
dépendance comment mieux accompagner
dans notre pays mieux aménager la ville
les transports pour faire en sorte que
les personnes âgées s'y sentent
davantage à l'aise comment enfin
accompagner le moment où la dépendance
survient nous devons ensemble répondre à
ces questions alors vous même madame la
sénatrice considérer que ces pistes de
réflexion serait est une évidence mais
si elle était si évidente que cela on se
demande pourquoi
au cours des années passées vous n'y
avez pas apporté les réponses
nécessaires et pourquoi le gouvernement
que vous avez soutenu n'a pas mise en
oeuvre les réformes qui à vous entendre
semble s'imposer et donc
ne suffit pas de considérer que les
rapports qui nous ont été présentés les
pistes de réflexion que nous engageons
et les pistes de réformes que nous
engageons irait de soi évidemment
lorsque le gouvernement présentera les
textes de loi nécessaires
la question du financement fera l'objet
de propositions précises
nous l'avons dit contrairement à la
majorité précédente nous ne pensons pas
que le financement de l'ue soutient la
dépendance passe par les assurances
privées
c'est donc en nous appuyant sur un
financement solidaire que nous
apporterons les réponses nécessaires et
madame la sénatrice je ne doute pas que
nous pourrons compter à ce moment là sur
votre contribution et vos propositions
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
louis carrère pour le groupe socialiste
et apparentés merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères et
porte sur le mali où notre diplomatie et
notre défense mène aujourd'hui une
action qui honore notre pays
le calendrier tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre la france n'a pas vocation à
rester au mali a dit le président de la
république
mais qui peut dire aujourd'hui quand
nous pourrons partir rapport de l'onu le
ver mars début du retrait de nos soldats
et résolutions du conseil de sécurité en
avril déploiement des casques bleus en
juillet monsieur le ministre ce
calendrier optimiste et piles réellement
tenable le processus politique
ensuite seuls les maliens peuvent
refonder un pacte national qui rassemble
toutes les communautés mais si la
feuille de route est mise en oeuvre de
façon contrastée
je partage naturellement l'objectif des
élections conditions de la légitimité
des institutions
là encore pourra-t-on édité plusieurs
millions de cartes électorales d'ici
et 7 et 21 juillet c'est un peu triviale
j'en conviens mais néanmoins il faut le
faire le financement de surcroît reste à
trouver et dans le nord ce qui me
préoccupe beaucoup plus l'administration
n'est pas complètement restauré en faire
beaucoup plus préoccupant la
réconciliation elle est par nature
douloureuses et difficiles
certes la commission dialogue et
réconciliation enfin pourrais je dire
été créés mais dispose-t-elle du souffle
de l'élan nécessaire ne serait-elle
qu'engage pour la communauté
internationale
cette question est intimement liée à
celle du respect des droits de l'homme
monsieur le ministre
quelles actions mènent la france pour
aider le procureur de la cour pénale
internationale et vis-à-vis des
autorités maliennes qu'elle suit
réserveront tel au récent rapport du
conseil des droits de l'homme
car pour moi comme pour vous sur tous
les bancs c'est l'impunité qui nourrit
la haine et le plus souvent entre a de
la réconciliation
je vous remercie merci monsieur laurent
fabius ministre affaires étrangères
c'est le président monsieur le président
carrère mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vos observations vos questions
monsieur plus à carrer sont extrêmement
pertinentes et précises
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
france avec ses partenaires est en train
de gagner la guerre au mali et il faut
que nous fassions efforts les uns et les
autres pour qu'elles s'associent gagner
la paix sur la guerre je saisis cette
occasion pour rendre une fois de plus
hommage à l'autre au qui ont fait un
travail magnifique
en s'exposant ainsi que nos amis
tchadien souvent au péril de leur vie
l'adrar des iforas ce est en train
d'être scruté les théories sont
débusquées 1
il reste un travail important à faire
dans la région de gao
mais on peut dire que grâce au travail
des uns et des autres la guerre est en
train d'être gagné il y a
en préparation vous l'avez dit le
président carrère un passage du
dispositif actuel appelé misma à une
opération de maintien de la paix sous le
contrôle de l'onu
cela donnera une dimension de
coordination une dimension politique une
dimension civile une dimension de
financement pérenne aussi qui sera bien
utile et je confirme les dates que vous
avez dit
une décision sera prise et à votes au
mois d'avril
et tout ceci pourra s'appliquer au mois
de juillet bien sûr il ya l'aspect
démocratique pas de sécurité sans
démocratie pas de démocratie sans
sécurité ce qui veut dire à la fois le
dialogue et la réconciliation ce ne sera
pas facile mais le 6 mars le conseil des
ministres malien a pris les décisions
nécessaires
et puis l'organisation des élections et
il faut que nous tous ici intervenons
auprès des formations politiques
maliennes pour répéter qu'il est
indispensable que ces élections aient
lieu alors date la date a été fixée au
mois de juillet et les dispositions
pratiques peuvent parfaitement être
prises enfin il y a bien évidemment la
question de l'impunité
vous avez dit ce qu'il fallait dire il
ne peut pas y avoir de démocratie s'il
n'y a pas de justice il ne peut pas y
avoir de justice s'il n'ya pas de lutte
contre l'impunité que ce soit à la
commission des droits de l'homme que ce
soit la cour pénale internationale
la france est aux côtés de tous ceux qui
se battent pour le droit
la madame là il a agi pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur moscovici ministre
de l'économie et des finances monsieur
le ministre nous prenons acte de
l'accord de compétitivité signé ce
mercredi entre la majorité des syndicats
et la direction de renault
mais ils interpellent il pose la
question d'un inquiétant déséquilibre en
contrepartie du maintien en activité des
usines sur le sol français
cet accord prévoit notamment 7500
suppressions nettes d'emploi d'ici fin
une augmentation de 6,5 pour cent du
temps de travail et un gel des salaires
pour l'année 2013 à en croire la
direction ces sacrifices seraient
inhérents à la conjoncture actuelle
monsieur le ministre force est de
reconnaître que ce sont toujours les
mêmes
toujours les mêmes les ouvriers les
employés les salariés les intérimaires
et les contribuables qui paient le prix
d'une inconséquence en termes de
stratégie de telles conditions au
maintien de l'activité de renault en
france sont inacceptables car sa
direction c'est bel et bien engouffré
dans une impasse
celle ci est le résultat d'une stratégie
parfaitement orchestré et non la
conséquence imprévisible d'une
conjoncture exceptionnelle les choix
opérationnels de la marque ont été
guidés par les seuls intérêts des
actionnaires privés sans vision moyen et
long terme pour l'avenir du groupe
voici comment les délocalisations
massives ont été privilégiés au
détriment de l'emploi dans l'hexagone
en effet depuis les débuts de l'alliance
nouée avec nissan il ya une quinzaine
d'années renault a progressivement
transférer les enjeux du hawk de haut de
gamme vers la marque japonaise en
délaissant les sites français
ensuite cette politique délibérée a
conduit une surcapacité des usines
renault sur notre sol voilà pourquoi les
raisons conjoncturelles invoquée par la
direction sont non seulement infondées
mais elle s'apparente à un déni de
réalité voir de la mauvaise foi ses
choix stratégiques ont conduit à une
autre conséquence tout aussi funeste la
désindustrialisation et
l'appauvrissement du tissu économique
français depuis des années renault
certes entreprise mondialisée
à délaisser les pme nationales pour
privilégier des fournisseurs étrangers
au nom d'une meilleure compétitivité
prix laquelle est loin d'être démontrée
j'en veux pour preuve
l'usiné de douai qui importe des joints
d'étanchéité de turquie au même coût que
ceux de son fournisseur historique de
normandie et que dire monsieur le
ministre de l'imprévoyance dramatique
des grands stratèges de renault qui sont
passés directement du véhicule thermique
au tout électrique
ignorant la demande pour la voix la
voiture hybride avec 15% du capital
l'état est le premier actionnaire de
renault
il subventionne au prix fort la
production et la vente en france des
véhicules de la marque
souvenez vous du grand emprunt 2009 et
du prêt avantageux de trois milliard
accordés par l'état la marque
monsieur le ministre vous avez pris la
mesure des enjeux des enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux des choix de renault je
n'en doute pas nous écologistes sommes
très attachés à la transition écologique
de l'économie
quelles mesures le gouvernement
compte-t-il prendre notamment en terme
de gouvernance et d'éco conditionnalité
pour ne plus faire supporter aux
contributions l'inconséquence de la
politique industrielle et commerciale du
constructeur
comment s'articulera t-il avec l'accord
national interpol et la parole est à
monsieur pierre moscovici ministre
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice elachi je
vous réponds en lieu et place de mon
collègue arnaud montebourg qui est en
déplacement et vous nous interroger sur
la stratégie du constructeur renault
d'abord vous le savez renault a choisi
déjà plusieurs années de faire alliance
ça s'appelle alliance avec le
constructeur japonais nissan
cette alliance a eu des avantages et des
inconvénients
en tout cas elle a offert à renault une
taille critique et un accès aux marchés
internationaux qui est appréciable en
termes de crise et il faut aussi en tire
les conséquences en terme de stratégie
cette alliance elle permet à ce
constructeur de présenter des résultats
meilleurs que d'autres
mais je vous rejoins sur ce point ne
l'exonère pas des difficultés de
l'industrie automobile sur notre
continent et notamment dans notre pays
dans cette situation
un accord a été négocié et signé il ya
quelques jours entre la direction et
trois organisations syndicales avec la
direction
représentant 65% des salariés alors
d'abord vous m'interrogez sur le lien
avec l'accord national
interprofessionnel je dirais que même si
celui ci n'est pas encore traduit dans
les faits notamment dans les textes ça
vous reviendra il ya quand même une
anticipation et je veux saluer ici
souligner deux choses d'abord la méthode
de négociation
cet accord vous pouvez le juger comme
vous le souhaitez mais c'est un accord
entre partenaires sociaux et un accord
majoritaire
deuxièmement il s'est cristallisé et là
dessus je vous rassure et autour d'un
certain nombre d'éléments que le
gouvernement avait lui même exigé aucun
licenciement
aucun plan de départs volontaires aucune
fermeture de site industriel faire en
sorte aussi que l'effort soit partagé et
il ya eu des contreparties
renault a accepté des contreparties en
terme de relocalisation
ça se traduit par le fait qu'il ya un
engagement concret à l'horizon 2016 il
porte sur sept cent dix mille véhicules
alors qu'aujourd'hui nous en sommes à
500 1000 et à l'horizon 2 au delà de
c'est un engagement qui se traduit par
un objectif commun de huit cent vingt
mille véhicules soit 100 % des capacités
de production aujourd'hui existantes sur
le sol national
il ya eu aussi des investissements qui
ont été consentis 420 millions d'euros à
des 230 millions à sandouville 190
millions à dieppe 300 millions à cléon
sur le véhicule électrique vous avez
votre jugement je pense que c'est là une
production d'avenir c'est un pari sur
l'avenir un pari sans doute nécessaire
et qui va dans le sens là je le
revendique et je les assume des
priorités qui ont été définies par le
gouvernement dans le cadre son plan
automobile
dernière chose c'est vrai que c'est un
accord qui implique des sacrifices et
ses sacrifices ces efforts il doit être
partagée
je vous indiquais ici que je considère
toujours que le dirigeant principal de
renault doit apporter sa part c'est ce
qui fait que nous avons voté contre sa
rémunération lorsqu'elle a été proposé
au conseil d'administration il faudra
que ça se débloque pas là les éléments
que je voulais vous apporter sur cet
accord qui tout même permet des progrès
merci la parole est un monsieur
michel le scouarnec pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
alors que demain la terrible wass des
expulsions locatives devait reprendre
vous avez fait le choix regard des
conditions métérologiques de repousser
de quinze jours la fin de la trêve
hivernale pour autant ces pratiques
seront elles plus acceptable en 15 jours
parce qu'ils subissent de plein fouet
les conséquences de la crise
trop de nos concitoyens se voit privé de
la garantie de ce droit fondamental
reconnu par notre constitution ce que
celui d'avoir un toit pour dormir un
toit pour s'épanouir un toit pour
rebondir mis à la rue c'est le
basculement le plus souvent sans retour
c'est le chemin menant à l'exclusion et
à la misère c'est l'humain qui est
sacrifié pour preuve 113000 décision
d'expulsion locative 12000 recours à la
force publique pour l'année 2011 et
autant de drames d'humains qu'en
sera-t-il en 2013 alors que la pression
immobilière reste fort que le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens stagnent les
exigences des bailleurs sont telles que
des centaines de milliers de familles se
trouvent en difficultés pour se loger
que dire des moyens des collectivités
qui ont stagné voire diminué les
empêchant de mener des politiques de
construction à la hauteur des besoins
les crédits de la mission logement font
les frais d'une politique de
restrictions confirmée par monsieur le
ministre du budget pour l'année 2014
avec 5 milliards d'économies
supplémentaires à trouver comment
construire alors une politique
permettant de garantir le droit au
logement pour tous l'exigence de
solidarité voudrait que soit créé un
véritable service public sorte de
sécurité sociale du logement
le collectif des 33 associations unies
pour une nouvelle politique du logement
vous ont demandé de déclarer un
moratoire sur les expulsions locatives
pour l'année 2013
en 2011 nous avions soumis une
proposition de loi permettant
l'interdiction des expulsions locatives
sans relogement pour les personnes qui
n'ont pas les moyens de se maintenir
dans les lieux le sénat d'hier alors
majoritairement à droite avait rejeté
ce texte vous avez depuis amorcer le
changement en prenant utilement une
circulaire pour interdire l'expulsion
des dalots nous vous demanderons donc
d'aller plus loin en décidant en urgence
au moratoire sur ces pratiques d'un
autre âge moratoire qui constitue une
exigence morale et politique pour le
respect des droits humains dont la
dignité de la personne
merci la parole et à madame najat
vallaud belkacem ministre les droits des
femmes merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur le scouarnec
je vous prie d'excuser l'absence de ma
collègue cécile duflot qui est retenu
par ailleurs mais j'ai plaisir à vous
répondre sur cette question majeure en
effet sur laquelle je voudrais commencer
par vous dire la mobilisation totale du
gouvernement pour prendre en charge les
personnes sans abri et les personnes mal
logées dont nous savons le nombre trop
important
mobilisation qui s'est manifesté je
crois ces derniers mois à plusieurs
reprises d'abord dès le mois de
septembre dernier lorsque le premier
ministre jean-marc ayrault a décidé de
mobiliser une enveloppe de 50 millions
d'euros pour répondre à l'urgence est de
mettre en place un plan hivernal
anticipé et renforcer dès le mois
d'octobre qui a suivi les ministres
cécile duflot et manuel valls sont en
particulier demandé aux préfets de
veiller à reloger systématiquement les
ménages menacés d'expulsion reconnu par
ailleurs prioritaire aux termes de la
loi dalo
avant même que n'intervienne la force
publique
en effet à cela s'ajoute aujourd'hui des
circonstances exceptionnelles vous
l'avez dit lié aux conditions
climatiques qui nous ont amenés à
décider de prolonger la période de trêve
hivernale
concernant les expulsions locatives ce
qui fait que concrètement il n'y aura
aucun recours au concours de la force
publique d'ici le 31 mars prochain
cela étant votre question est juste que
se passe-t-il après et là encore sachez
qu'une circulaire a été adressée au
préfet de région le 4 janvier dernier au
terme de laquelle il leur est demandé
d'éviter la remise à la rue
des personnes qui étaient précédemment
accueillis dans ce dispositif hivernal
concrètement nous mettons en oeuvre un
principe qui est simple un principe de
continuité de prise en charge et nous
proposons un dispositif d'accueil pour
ces personnes qui soient à la fois
pérenne et solide et qui passe bien
entendu d'abord par des places
d'hébergement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé cette année de créer sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat 5000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence supplémentaires
nous avons par ailleurs décidé la
création de 7000 places d'intermédiation
locative en alternative à l'hébergement
et nous avons enfin décider seul à
répondre à votre interrogation
l'accélération du relogement des ménages
reconnus prioritaires aux termes de la
loi dalo
enfin je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement travaille en ce moment même
à la mise en oeuvre d'une garantie
universelle des loyers une forme de
couverture universelle qui va permettre
à la fois de mettre un terme aux
expulsions et en même temps aux
expulsions dont qui intervenait pour
impayés de loyer et en même temps de
garantir les revenus des propriétaires
car c'est un véritable sujet aussi cette
garantie interviendra très prochainement
monsieur le sénateur vous le voyez
l'ambition et l'engagement du
gouvernement en la matière ne sont plus
à démontrer je crois et nous allons
continuer merci la parole est à madame
françoise laborde pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
garde des sceaux
hier matin en conseil des ministres
quatre textes étaient présentés ayant
pour objet tous les quatre de réviser la
constitution et d'honorer ainsi des
engagements de campagne du président de
la république
mais force est de constater que le
conseil des ministres a adopté une
révision constitutionnelle très a minima
par rapport aux attentes et aux
engagements aussi ma question ne
porte-t-elle pas sur les projets de loi
présentés hier mais sur l'un des trois
ou quatre textes absents et pourtant
très attendu cher au coeur des membres
du groupe rdse et dont il semble ne plus
être question
contrairement aux autres cette absence
ne s'expliquerait pas par des
considérations arithmétiques liée à une
nécessaire majorité des trois cinquièmes
des parlementaires
vous l'aurez compris je veux parler de
l'engagement numéro 46 du candidat
soutenu il vient non par le parti
socialiste et le parti radical de gauche
quel était cet engagement je vous le
rappelle in extenso
je proposerai d'inscrire les principes
fondamentaux de la loi de 1905 sur la
laïcité dans la constitution
en insérant à l'article 1er un deuxième
alinéa ainsi rédigé la république assure
la liberté de conscience garantit le
libre service des cultes et respecte la
séparation des églises et de l'état
conformément au titre 1er de la loi de
1905 sous réserve des règles
particulières applicables en alsace et
moselle
cet engagement est il sur le point de
passer par pertes et profits au prétexte
peut-être qu'une récente décision du
conseil constitutionnel a rappelé que la
laïcité avait une valeur
constitutionnelle
sauf dans les trois départements du
concordat est d'ailleurs le moment
n'est-il pas venu de mettre fin à cette
exception hérités de l'histoire
madame la garde des sceaux vous savez
l'importance et le rôle du principe
universel de laïcité dans l'émancipation
des hommes et les femmes
vous savez aussi combien la laïcité est
une valeur républicaine fragile et vous
n'ignorez pas non plus les tentatives de
dévoiement et les menaces dont elle fait
l'objet de la part des extrêmes oui la
laïcité mérite toute notre attention
elles méritent notre protection alors
que la laïcité vient de perdre l'un de
ses plus ardents défenseurs
notre collègue henri caillavet grandes
figures du radicalisme et parlementaires
d'exception le gouvernement at il
renoncé à l'engagement numéro 46 si oui
quelle mesure entente il prendre en
faveur du principe de laïcité
madame la garde des sceaux les français
sont très attachés à la laïcité et ses
plus ardents défenseurs dont nous sommes
attendent un signe fort ils attendent
eux aussi une fumée blanche qui tarde à
venir
merci merci madame christiane taubira
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice françoise laborde
madame la sénatrice je connais votre
attachement personnel et politique que à
la laïcité en tant que valeurs
fondamentales et en tant que principe de
concorde très largement partagée
indiscutablement et c'est un socle qui
nous permet sur un certain nombre de
textes d'obtenir des convergences et
parfois l'unanimité madame la sénatrice
c'est ce principe de concorde qui nous
permet de faire société
en égalité vous avez raison de rappeler
que ce principe de laïcité reconnaît
toutes les croyances mais reconnaît la
liberté de conscience et que la
république elle même c'est indiqué dans
la loi ne reconnaît ni ne salarie aucun
culte réserves faites des territoires où
s'appliquent encore les dispositions
concordataire 7 ce principe de laïcité
est essentiel on peut considérer
d'ailleurs que il prend sa source dans
l'idée même de la république c'est ce
que nous pouvons déduire de l'article 10
de la déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen mais c'est vrai
qu'il fallu des décennies de combat pour
aboutir à cette loi de 1905 qui établit
très clairement la séparation de l'état
des églises et qui finalement définit le
cadre que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
encore de la vie commune dans la cité
dans le rapport public et privé aux
religions
le président de la république l'a dit
très clairement il y aura d'autres
réformes constitutionnelles il y lit il
est certain que la question de la
laïcité pose la question des influences
sur les institutions de l'état et ce
n'est pas une question mineure
vous avez rappelé d'ailleurs que
récemment une décision du conseil
constitutionnel saisi par une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité à
renforcer les principes fondamentaux de
la loi de 1905 a rappelé que le principe
de laïcité relève des droits et des
libertés et a donc consolidé ce qui est
contenu dans notre loi de 1905 le
gouvernement le président la république
s'est engagé en décembre 2012 à faire
installer prochainement le
l'observatoire nationale de la laïcité
qui a été créé par décret depuis 2007
mais qui n'a pas été mise en oeuvre le
gouvernement travaille à sa mise en
oeuvre et il sera installé dans les
prochaines semaines il assistera le
gouvernement pour le respect du principe
de laïcité dans tous les services
publics
toutes ces dispositions nous aideront à
avancer vers l'élaboration d'une bonne
réforme constitutionnelle qui tiendra
compte de l'engagement numéro 46 du
président la république
merci la parole et à monsieur roger
karoutchi pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
ma question s'adresse à vous parce que
l'île de france veut redevenir ce
qu'elle était dans le passé c'est à dire
le moteur de la croissance de notre pays
le projet qui avait été lancée par
nicolas sarkozy du grand paris était un
projet qui à la fois devait améliorer
les transports et la vie quotidienne des
franciliens mais aussi recréer cette
dynamique
les arbitrages de la semaine dernière du
premier ministre ont connu sur les
tracés il peut y avoir débat mais
globalement tout le monde est d'accord
en revanche monsieur le ministre il ya
des réserves les miennes mais celle de
beaucoup sur à la fois le phasage
jusqu'en 2030 au delà et sur le fait que
curieusement les pôles de développement
essentiel roissy orly la défense sont
dans la dernière phase or voilà un grand
paris express qui coûte 26 milliards sur
lequel je le dis tout de suite pour
assurer le président gaudin l'état dit
éventuellement nous mettrons un milliard
ci a besoin ce qui veut dire qu'en
réalité l'essentiel pour ne pas dire la
totalité de la dépense
elle est assurée par les collectivités
franciliennes par les franciliennes par
les entreprises non mais je veux dire
par là il n'y a pas de demande de la
part des franciliens envers l'état et
c'est bien comme ça en revanche monsieur
le ministre
l'ile-de-france ses 19 % de la
population
c'est 30 % de la recette fiscale le
projet du grand paris
ces 150 mille emplois c'est un point de
croissance
ces 50 milliards de ressources fiscales
supplémentaires pour l'état dans les
tropes dans les 30 années qui viennent
50 milliards de ressources fiscales
supplémentaires dont mes chers collègues
une partie très naturellement ne revient
pas sur l'île de france mais comme
toujours dans la dépense puisque sur les
30 % de recettes fiscales de
l'ile-de-france 22% sont re consacrés
par l'état l'ile-de-france le reste et
c'est bien normal sur une péréquation
d'état indépendamment des péréquations
législatives qui existe ça veut dire
quoi monsieur le ministre de l'économie
ça veut dire que nous avons le sentiment
que le fait de pouvoir réaliser ce
projet que le fait de mettre en avant
les grands pôles de développement très
vite
que le fait de faire en sorte que les
travaux démarrent rapidement
c'est un élément de croissance de
création d'emplois et d'enrichissement
pour les tailles par conséquent pour
l'ensemble du pays et nous vous
demandons d'intervenir vous en tant que
miss de l'économie avec l'aspect
budgétaire et financier pour dire
attention
commençons web qui vont les secteurs qui
par définition sont ceux qui peuvent
entraîner le mouvement le plus
rapidement faisons en sorte de créer la
dynamique lorsque le premier ministre
dit après 2020 on n'est plus très sûr du
financement
je vous dis seulement attention faisant
sort tous ensemble de réussir ce grand
paris et ce grand projet national
merci la parole à monsieur pierre
moscovici ministre l'économie et des
finances monsieur le sénateur roger
karoutchi
je veux excuser ici le premier mystique
vous le savez tous est en déplacement au
canada et qui m'a demandé de pouvoir
répondre à votre question premier
ministre a présenté mercredi 6 mars
l'ambition du gouvernement pour l'île de
france et quand j'ai de l'ambition du
gouvernement vous adressez à moi c'est
bien l'ambition de tout le gouvernement
que le premier est rapportée vous avez
eu raison de dire que le défi du grand
paris c'est un défi franciliens bien sûr
mais c'est plus largement un enjeu de
développement économique pour la france
entière et nous souhaitons comme vous et
je pense que c'est partager sur tous les
bancs que l'île de france soit un pôle
extrêmement important le principal dans
le développement du pays en tant que
disait commis des finances je sais
l'importance de paris du grand paris
dans le développement économique de
notre pays
le projet du gouvernement il incarne une
politique de développement
un modèle de développement une politique
d'investissement que nous défendons
c'est un modèle de croissance bien sûr
mais qui n'oublie ni la solidarité entre
les franciliens ni le désenclavement des
territoires
un modèle de croissance ou la mobilité
va de pair avec un effort pour le
logement des français et pour leur cadre
de vie
le premier ministre a en particulier
présenter les décisions du volant pour
le schéma des transports du nouveau
grand paris qui articule la rénovation
du réseau existant et la création de
nouvelles lignes dans un schéma global
sans distinction entre ce qu'il a était
d'usagé d'appeler le plan de
mobilisation d'autre part et le grand
paris express
d'autre part je vous le rappeler ici
d'ici à 2030
l'ensemble du réseau du grand paris
express sera réalisée les lignes étant
lancée en parallèle et faisant l'objet
d'une réalisation continue et c'est un
chantier très important
vous appelez à cela vous serez satisfait
au delà puisque les capacités
d'ingénierie des bureaux d'études
l'outil industriel les entreprises de
travaux publics se sont mobilisés pour
plus de cinq ans et plus concrètement
d'ici à 2017
il ya deux milliards d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront affectés à la
modernisation des lignes existantes qui
permettront de porter les engagements
possibles à 7 milliards d'euros
c'est un effort sans précédent bien sûr
des discussions seront poursuivis qui
permettra aux franciliens de disposer de
transport de qualité au quotidien et
cela sans attendre conforteront
l'attractivité de la région ile de
france pour les entreprises la recherche
universitaire est privé donc la qualité
de vie et l'ensemble des pôles de la
région ile de france je peux vous
l'assurer seront pris en compte pour que
tout ceci se réalise il faudra une
réforme institutionnelle bâtiment en
matière de logement et d'aménagement et
vous savez que le gouvernement propose
une intercommunalité renforcée en
ile-de-france la création la métropole
de paris ainsi que les pouvoirs
renforcés à l'échelle régionale pour
garantir davantage de justice et
équilibre dans la politique d'habitat je
voulais donc vous rassurer monsieur le
sénateur il ya là un choix ambitieux qui
a été fait pour le gouvernement qui est
à la hauteur de l'enjeu
il appartiendra au parlement de s'en
saisir mais vous pouvez faire confiance
à la volonté du gouvernement et à celle
du premier ministre personne merci la
parole à monsieur jean pierre sueur pour
le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de la justice
nous voulons ardemment de la
modernisation de la vie publique
tellement nécessaire dans ce pays par
exemple pour ce qui est de
l'indépendance du parquet que vous
respectez
scrupuleusement comme le fit naguère
madame marylise lebranchu
nous vous demandons madame la ministre
quelles sont vos intentions pour que
cette indépendance soit la plus complète
et totale possible ce qui n'exclura pas
les circulaires pénale que vous
produisez régulièrement de même
s'agissant du statut juridictionnelle du
chef de l'état qui a tellement attendu
quand va-t-il venir la suppression de la
cour de justice de la république de
manière à ce qu'il y ait une procédure
plus conforme au droit commun pour nos
ministres encore la nécessité d'aller
plus loin
s'agissant de la décentralisation nous
voulons une réforme qui soit simple
claire lisible offensive et qu'ils
soient dynamiques pour la france du
xxième siècle
le cumul des mandats sur lequel il
faudra avancer de manière passionnée s
en est sans hésitation et enfin la
démocratie mais je m'adresse à tous le
monde monsieur l'archet vous le voyez
bien et enfin la démocratie look social
qu'il importe d'inscrire au sein de
notre constitution
sur tous ces sujets des décisions ont
été prises
d'autres le seront madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous éclairer sur le
calendrier
quand on mettre en oeuvre le
gouvernement de manière à ce que cette
modernisation de la vie publique qui
doit être mise en oeuvre le soin sans
tarder ici et maintenant je vous
remercie
merci madame plus symptômes ira garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le président mesdames la
sénatrice mme sur le sénateur messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur
sénateur jean pierre sueur président la
commission des lois monsieur le
président comme vous le savez alors en
deux oui je voulais bien dit monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
vous pouvez vous pouvez me faire grief
de nombreuses choses mais pas la
courtoisie en particulier en particulier
devant nos assemblées mais vous vous
lorsque vous avez annoncé plusieurs
sujets je pourrais évidemment vous
répondre par des pétitions de principe
sur chacun de ces sujets en deux heures
en deux minutes et demie il ne me serais
pas permis de faire mieux que cela
je vais simplement rappelé que ce
mercredi le premier ministre a présenté
en conseil des ministres les quatre
projets de loi de réforme
constitutionnelle qui sont présentés
devant le parlement cette présentation
est irritante ayant été faite devant le
conseil des ministres
il appartient maintenant au parlement de
l'inscrire dans le calendrier
parlementaire il est prévu normalement
que ces textes soient examinés aux
environs de l'été je vous rappelle le
contenu de ce texte donc le premier vous
avez insistait d'ailleurs sur
l'importance de respecter l'engagement
du président de la république sur
l'indépendance du parquet et il est vrai
que la première réforme
constitutionnelle concerne la réforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
c'est un engagement du président de la
république sur l'indépendance parce que
le président a bien exprimé que pour lui
la confiance des citoyens dans les
institutions et en particulier dans
l'institution judiciaire relève du pacte
républicain est une condition vitale
pour le pacte républicain et cette
réforme ne sera pas une réforme a minima
c'est une réforme audacieuse il
appartiendra au parlement assemblée
nationale et sénat d'en préciser le
contenu et les contours mais déjà le
projet de loi gouvernemental indique
bien qu'il faut mettre un terme à l'ère
du soupçon qu'il faut consolider la
légitimité des magistrats et en
particulier des magistrats du parquet
qu'il faut consolider
à condition de l'impartialité assuré
donc cette indépendance
non pas pour le confort des juges mais
pour la sécurité des justiciables pour
soi évidemment il faut ensemble de
conditions
la première c'est la proposition de ce
conseil super de la magistrature il n'y
aurait plus de personnalité qualifiée
désignée par le pouvoir politique
la seconde condition on y vient c'est ce
sont les conditions de nomination
un avis conforme pour les magistrats du
parquet comme pour les magistrats du
siège
ensuite un alignement du régime
disciplinaire
tout cela conforte ce qui est déjà
inscrit dans la constitution
l'unité du corps ce gouvernement s'est
déjà imposé de respecter cette
disposition puisque nous ne donnons plus
de d'instruction individuelle
évidemment nous continuons à assurer la
responsabilité sur la politique pénale
mais dans l'ensemble du territoire mais
bien entendu nous allons consolider tout
cela dans la loi merci monsieur le
président merci la parole est à madame
catherine brault kassian groupe union
pro musulman populaire
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse donc à madame touraine
après avoir tant critiqué la réforme des
retraites engagée par françois fillon en
la qualifiant d' un juge de nos finances
et je me réjouis que le président
françois hollande alors ce que le
gouvernement est enfin prêt à faire des
choix courageux pour assurer l'avenir de
nos régimes de retraite mais que feront
ils
le rapport du conseil d'orientation des
retraites dit clairement qu'il nous faut
trouver 20 milliards d'ici 2020 pour
éviter la faillite du système 20
milliards et non pas 47 qui aurait été
nécessaire si nous n'avions pas engager
la réforme en 2010 le bout demandant
d'abandonner vous attaque vous
reconnaissez enfin que l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie doit être pris en
considération
ce n'est pourtant pas un fait qui date
d'hier ni de mai 2012
madame la ministre dimanche vous avez
déclaré que des efforts seraient demandé
à tous les français puisque touché l'âge
de départ semble complètement
abou à quels efforts pensez vous le
gouvernement doit être claire et honnête
envers les français
oserez-vous leur annoncer qu'ils devront
cotiser plus de 41 ans et demi ils ne
sont pas idiots ils vont faire le calcul
et ils verront que les 62 ans ne sont
qu'un leurre mais même cela ne suffira
pas vous le savez en faisant sauter le
verrou des 62 ans cet été vous avez
donné un signal contradictoire aux
français et dépensé 3 milliards mais
vous avez aussi contraint les régimes
complémentaires a décidé de désindexer
les pensions après avoir instauré à
l'automne une nouvelle contribution à la
charge et retraités
allez vous continuer à les paupérisés et
sont moins des nantis que vous aimez le
faire croire je voudrais donc vous poser
trois questions précise madame la
ministre que comptez-vous faire avec les
salariés des régimes spéciaux vont ils
continuer être exemptés des futurs
efforts à pouvoir partir en retraite à
52 ans comme les cheminots ou à 57 ans
comme les autres agents de la sncf et de
la ratp
deuxième question prenez-vous
aujourd'hui madame la ministre
l'engagement de présenter votre réforme
devant le parlement et non de légiférer
par ordonnance comme le suggère votre
parte parole
enfin député vous réclamiez une réforme
garantit financièrement jusqu'à 2030
celle que vous allez nous proposer
aura-t-elle des ambitions de celles que
vous nous réclamiez merci madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice catherine procaccia oui
effectivement nous avons indiqué que la
réforme du précédent gouvernement
n'était ni juste ni financer et si
d'ailleurs votre réforme avait été juste
et financer nous n'aurions pas besoin
aujourd'hui de remettre l'ouvragé sur le
métier
et c'est parce que votre réforme était
injuste que nous avions pris
l'engagement et que nous avons obtenu
l'engagement dès notre arrivée aux
responsabilités de permettre à celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
jeunes qui ont la totalité de leurs
années cotisées de pouvoir partir en
retraite dès 60 ans et c'est parce que
votre réforme n'étaient pas financés que
nous avons dû engager des travaux nous
permettant d'amorcer une nouvelle
réforme vous me permettrez madame la
sénatrice de saisir l'occasion que vous
me donnez pour saluer l'engagement des
partenaires sociaux et leur sens des
responsabilités qui leur a permis
d'aboutir à un compromis
cette nuit leur engagement pour que les
régimes complémentaires de retraite qui
contribue pour une part significative à
la retraite des salariés ayant travaillé
dans le privé soit assurée dans la durée
parce que voyez vous madame la sénatrice
et cela à l'exigence du gouvernement
c'est de faire en sorte dans la durée
nos régimes de retraite par répartition
soit garanti c'est de faire en sorte que
dans la durée les français puissent
compter sur une retraite versées grâce à
la solidarité nationale or aujourd'hui
les jeunes générations sont inquiètes
nous avons donc commandé un rapport au
sec d'orientation des retraites qui a
été rendue mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qui a été rendu et qui fait
état d'un déficit de l'ordre de 20
milliards d'euros d'ici
1020 une commission s'est installée qui
auditionnera notamment les partenaires
sociaux aboutir à des pistes de
propositions qui devront nous permettre
d'agir dans trois directions la première
c'est celle du financement à court terme
de nos régimes de retraites pour que les
français soient assurés de la pérennité
de nos régimes la deuxième orientation
qui a été prise par le gouvernement
c'est celle de consolider dans la durée
les régimes de retraite par répartition
et enfin nous nous sommes engagés à
introduire des mesures d'équité
ces mesures nous allons y travailler je
ne doute pas madame la sénatrice que
vous y apporteraient une contribution
utile pour l'ensemble des français
merci la parole la parole à monsieur
jean françois mallet pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
des ministes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame delphine batho
ministre de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie
elle n'est pas là et je le regrette
madame la ministre
l'indre fait partie des sites dix
départements du centre sinistré au plan
ferroviaire dans ce domaine le polt
paris orléans limoges toulouse constitue
notre seul moyen actuel n'est sa
fiabilité sa vitesse et son confort
ressemble à celle et celui des années 60
il est aussi notre seule raison
d'espérer bénéficier d'une liaison
confortable et rapide entre paris et
toulouse et ainsi être connecté au
réseau et le gp national et européen
sa rénovation et sa connexion à la
future lgv pop paris orléans clermont
lyon sont pour nous essentiel l'exigence
légitime de la haute-vienne d'atteinte
paris en deux heures sera ainsi
respecter une nous pourrons du lot au
sud au cher au nord proposé à nos
habitants à deux reprises des temps de
parcours et un confort digne de notre
époque
malheureusement une partie des élus de
la haute vienne ont imaginé avec les
élus de la vienne un échappatoire vers
poitiers est de ceux là est né le projet
lg
et monovoie monovoie limoges poitiers
avec en échange la participation du
limousin au financement du segment lgv
manquant entre poitiers et bordeaux
ce projet est tellement fragile en terme
de prévisions d'activité que vous avez
imaginé fausser le débat public en
asséchant à dire très arbitrairement le
polt pour rendre plus crédible limoges
poitiers le courrier émanant du
ministère de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie mendiants
l'accord des élus financeurs pour cette
manoeuvre de détournement et cynique
injuste et totalement déplacé
ces procédés sont contraires aux règles
de la république ou et l'exigence
d'aménagement équitable du territoire
où est le respect de l'intérêt public où
est le respect de l'environnement
où est le respect de la bonne
utilisation de l'argent public dans
l'arborescence élu je vais nationale le
limoges poitiers monovoie est une
brindille
mais cette brindille coûte entre 1
milliard et demi et 3 milliards d'euros
au moment de saint lô salle de sa
réalisation dans le cadre des
contraintes budgétaires et du respect de
l'environnement qui sont les nôtres
la rénovation du pote et sa connexion au
peuple satisfont parfaitement aux
directives environnementales
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas du
projet doté de détournement par poitiers
moins coûteux plus équitable
techniquement et commercialement plus
productifs voilà les critères qui doit
être la priorité des élus du
gouvernement
les départements concernés attendent le
maintien d'un accès de matières d'un axe
polt rénové est connecté au peuple ce
qui impliquera le non détournement de sa
clientèle géographiquement naturel nous
comptons sur vous ainsi que sur le
gouvernement
merci monsieur alain vidalis ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur voudrait bien excuser l'absence
de madame bateau qui accompagne le
premier ministre dans un voyage officiel
au au canada
vous évoquez ici d'une part deux projets
de lgv la lgv poitiers limoges et la lgv
paris orléans clermont ferrand lyon dit
polk et d'autre part la ligne actuelle
paris orléans limoges toulouse dit polt
l'ensemble ces questions fait l'objet
d'une attention particulière du
gouvernement étant donné leur importance
en terme d'aménagement et de
développement de nos territoires
le projet de lgv poitiers limoges est
actuellement en phase préalable à
lenquête public
il s'agit d'une étape importante qui
nécessite que les collectivités
territoriales cofinanceurs soient
étroitement associés à l'élaboration du
dossier qui sera présentée au public
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
hypothèses concernant les différentes
possibilités de desserte tenant compte
des nouveaux services permis par la lgv
ont fait l'objet des changes entre
l'état rff et les collectivités
territoriales
l' enquête publique est une phase des
changes démocratique visant à recueillir
les expressions de l'ensemble des
acteurs à l'issue de laquelle le projet
peut être amené à évoluer les hypothèses
de desserte présentés dans le dossier d'
enquête sur l'avenir des dessertes de la
ligne polt sont une base de travail
permettant d'éclairer le débat à venir
elle ne préjuge pas des circulations sur
cette ligne qui relève de la convention
conclue entre l'état et la sncf portant
sur l'exploitation de l'ensemble des
trains d'équilibré du territoire
la lgv polk vient quant à elle de faire
l'objet d'un débat public achevée depuis
2012 et une nouvelle phase d'étude vient
d'être engagé il s'agira de définir les
conditions de la faisabilité financière
du projet d'approfondir son évaluation
socio-économique et de préciser les
performances des dessertes envisageable
la commission mobilité 21 est chargé
d'examiner les différents projets
d'infrastructures de transport dont ses
deux lgv et de proposer les orientations
pour une politique de transport
soutenable les conclusions de cette
commission sont attendus
d'ici la fin du mois de juin à notre
sens les lgv la ligne existence doivent
pas être considérés comme des
infrastructures en concurrence mais
complémentaires il n'y a en effet pas
question d'opposer les infrastructures
qui n'assure pas les mêmes services la
ligne polt devra ainsi continuer à
assurer une desserte fine des
territoires situés sur cet axe nord-sud
est essentielle à l'aménagement de notre
pays
ces différentes démarches sont engagées
dans une approche responsable et sont
nécessaires en préalable pour permettre
d'éclairer les décisions à prendre pour
l'avenir de notre réseau ferroviaire et
l'aménagement de nos territoires
très bien merci la parole à monsieur
vincent eblé pour le groupe socialiste
et apparentés monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
la france a le privilège d'avoir une
population âgée en croissance et nous
avons la chance que représente
l'allongement de la vie
mais avons nous réellement imaginer le
visage de la france dans une dizaine
d'années environ
les plus de 60 ans représenteront un
tiers de la population en 2035
alors qu'ils sont 1 5e aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une position enviable
puisque en parallèle de ce
vieillissement la france est une des
rares nations européennes à voir sa
population augmenter et c'est un
véritable atout
encore faut-il que nous soyons capables
d'anticiper ce changement afin d'adapter
notre société et plus particulièrement
les politiques publiques et ainsi
profiter de l'opportunité qui nous est
offerte cette opportunité avant d'être
charge est une opportunité humaine
transgénérationnel une opportunité
culturelle mais également une
opportunité économique avec le
développement de la croissance et des
emplois dans les secteurs liés aux
services à la personne aux nouvelles
technologies dédiées aux bâtiments avec
l'adaptation des logements nécessaires
au maintien à domicile
hélas
nous devons constater que cette réalité
démographique n'a pas été encore prise
en considération et que la société
française accuse un sérieux retard
promise par nicolas sarkozy en 2007
la réforme de la dépendance a été
repoussé tout au long du quinquennat est
définitivement abandonné en septembre
vous avez sur votre bureau madame la
ministre
trois très bons rapports respectivement
de madame mainville de messieurs akino
et broussy il démontre qu'au delà d'une
problématique de financement
la question de la perte d'autonomie
s'articule entre autres autour de la
prévention pour retarder au maximum la
dépendance mais également de notre
capacité de compréhension de ce que
signifie et nécessite le vieillissement
de la population en termes d'adaptation
de nos lois au congrès de l'uniopss le
président de la république a redit son
engagement à accomplir la réforme de la
perte d'autonomie et évoque la
finalisation d'un texte d'ici la fin de
l'année
preuve du sérieux de cette ambition le
financement de la réforme a été
partiellement amorcée dès le premier
budget de la sécurité sociale de notre
majorité
ma question madame la ministre pourriez
vous nous préciser quels sont les axes
prioritaires que le gouvernement compte
défendre dans cette future grande
réforme qui accompagnera l'adaptation de
la société au vieillissement merci
madame marisol touraine
monsieur le merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vincent eblé
il est exact que le vieillissement de la
population représente un grand défi pour
notre pays
des filles pour nos régimes de retraite
ce qui nous amènera à prendre des
mesures courageuses et ambitieuses pour
sauvegarder notre système de retraite
par répartition des filles aussi pour
faire en sorte que notre société soit
mieux adapté
à cette population qui avance en âge
trois rapports d'une très grande qualité
je vous remercie de l'avoir souligné ont
été remis à monsieur le premier ministre
il ya quelques jours par madame la
députée martine pinville monsieur luc
broussy et monsieur le professeur akino
ils vont nous permettre de faire des
propositions dans trois directions
la première de ces directions et celle
de l'anticipation de la dépendance faire
en sorte que la prévention soit reconnu
comme tel
il s'agit de permettre la détection des
fragilités des personnes âgées à travers
des dispositifs qui passeront à la fois
par l'assurance-maladie éventuellement
d'autres mécanismes mais qui permettront
de repérer les personnes susceptibles de
venir de devenir dépendantes
la deuxième orientation et celle de
l'adaptation de notre société nous le
savons les logements sont insuffisamment
adapter les transports ne permettent pas
toujours de faciliter les communications
des personnes âgées
michèle delaunay ministre des affaires
des personnes âgées de l'autonomie met
beaucoup l'accent sur ce qu'elle appelle
la silver economy
car il ya là des gisements pour le
développement de nouvelles activités
économiques et enfin la troisième
orientation c'est celle de la prise en
charge de l'accompagnement de la
dépendance elle même nous ne partons pas
de rien puisque si rien n'a été fait au
cours des dernières années le
gouvernement de lionel jospin les poser
le socle d'une prise en charge de la
dépendance grâce à l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie et c'est dans
cette direction que nous devons faire en
sorte que un meilleur service soit
rendue pour les personnes qu'elles
restent à domicile ou qu'elles
choisissent d'aller dans un
établissement pour personnes âgées
je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur
d'avoir souligné l'importance que revêt
cette réforme pour notre société et
d'avoir marqué l'importance que lui
accordent les sénateurs
merci mes chers collègues nous en avons
fini avec les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour la suite du projet
de loi modifié par l'assemblée nationale
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez donc pu suivre en direct sur notre
antenne on se retrouve tout de suite
avec nos invités pour refaire ensemble à
ses enfants